متى كانت احدث عمليات انقاذ من هذا النوع
قبل نصف قرن جرت عمليه انقاذ غواصه في
اعمق نقطه تم سحب غواصه منها في التاريخ
في سبتمبر من عام
1973 تم انتشالها وسط كنديه صغيره تتسع
لشخصين الى السطح من عمق 1600 قدم تحت سطح
البحر حينها قامت السفينه الام للغواصه
بفتح احدى فتحات الغواصه عن طريق الخطا ما
ادى الى ملء جزء من الغواصه
ببطين من مياه البحر وما ادى بالتالي الى
غرقها وبعد مرور ثلاثه ايام تم انقاذ
المغامرين مع بقاء اكسجين يكفي الاثنتي
عشره دقيقه فقط وربما ساهم في انقاذهم
انذاك انهما بقي على اتصال مع طواقم
الانقاذ
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات